and now we travel to leverkusen to meet
coach roger schmidt he made his
bundesliga coaching debut with the club
this past summer
and since his arrival the team has
gotten quicker and is on the offensive
schmidt has tweaked and fine-tuned their
training methods but then what else
would you expect from a former engineer
so how much does his former profession
influence his current job
mr schmidt do you still have checkered
shirts in your closet
checkered
apparently not all of them i can't
remember ever wearing a plaid shirt and
certainly not when i worked as a
mechanical engineer
not all stereotypes are true
you're probably right but you know what
i'm getting at your life before
professional soccer
it was never my plan to become a
professional coach or to coach at all
that's why i studied engineering
while i was a player i also worked as an
engineer
i only got my coaching license for fun
but things took another turn
yes it does even though i've only been a
coach for 9-10 years
but all that does seem very far away
it's likely due to the fact that in
soccer each season is distinctive
maybe that's what makes it seem longer
it's pretty intensive yeah that's
infinite absolutely everything you do
off the pitch can also help you in
soccer
especially if you've taken a different
direction in another phase of your life
if you've gained experience and above
all you've dealt with people and are
capable of taking responsibility finding
ahmed smith mentioned so
that's always important because as a
coach you must make decisions
what the coach says goes whether at
practice deciding the lineup or your
role in the organization in
you have to be sure of yourself
sure of your direction
and enjoy making decisions
otherwise it just doesn't work
during games you like to keep pushing
forward the ball should always go
forward
sure i just like offensive football and
i also like holding my fate in my own
hands
whether the ball goes in off the post or
out off the post is not something you
have complete control of
but the game situation as such is
something you can influence thereby
increasing your chances of
success that's why i'd rather a lot
happen during the whole 90 minutes not
just have a few skirmishes in front of
their respective goals and whoever
manages to shoot the ball in wins
that bugs you doesn't
this season it's annoyed me that
although we've often been the better
team we didn't win
yet i still believe that the way we play
is the best
of course when we play this way our
opponent must play an intensive game too
they can't say i'm not going to do much
that just doesn't work
they can play defensively
but they must play intensively to
prevent us from scoring goals
to be especially good in those areas the
better the opponent the better we have
to play our game and the more we have to
believe in ourselves
that's why even against teams like
bayern we try to find an area where we
might be better than they are
that's really tough
but there are a few facets of the game
where we can be better than buying
for instance
the things i've just said approaching
the ball very aggressively and well
during matches playing a ball-oriented
game having more people near the ball
and so forth
we're strong in that strong in getting
the ball back once we've lost it
those are things with which we can hurt
even the top teams